[cheers and applause]
-Welcome to
"This is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Ari Shaffir.
- Yeah.
- [screams]
-It's a storyteller show.
It's just a bunch
of funny people
telling 100% true stories.
-This is the first year
I have ever talked
about this onstage.
- Tonight the topic is...
-This woman is straddling
my face
with 12-inch black dildo
and Excaliburs it
into my mouth.
- [screams]
- Ah...
No, uh...
- Ka-blam!
-Yo, did you know
Osama bin Laden?
Do you want to meet
his brother?
Fuck yeah I do!
- I'm on fire.
My insides are burning.
I go to the doctor...
-And the doctor's like,
"Tell him we have to cut
the tip of his dick open."
- [shouts]
- Oh, my God.
- Like an existential shattering
of a human soul.
-Putting a penis in an eye
is a party stopper.
-On one explosion of life
I laughed out loud, peed one,
squirt, and farted in her face.
-A knock on the door.
It's the cops.
And I'm like,
"Oh, no thank you."
- In my house, blackmail,
larceny,
arson more than once.
-I am on drugs!
I'm sorry, sir!
Don't call my dad!
- Percocet, a lot of mushrooms.
- Cocaine.
- We're lost because we're high.
And we're ten.
- Yeah, my friend Stan has got
all the puppies.
He's got 'em.
Get in the van.
- I'm practically insane.
-If I don't trust to usedcondom
with a regular human woman,
you'll be goddamned if I just
give it to a homeless lady.
-She could be actively
sucking my dick
and dudes would still be going,
"What are you doing later?"
- Shut up!
Shut up!
- It's my first time terrorizing
anyone.
I'm going balls to the wall.
-It was louder than any
jet engine.
It was...
[shouting]
- [screams]
- I am going to...
[inaudible]
And I'm going to drink a sip
of his blood,
because I fucking hated
[inaudible].
-One of you motherfuckers
is like,
"Joey, you can't hit a woman."
She's a fucking nun.
Big fucking difference, okay?
Big fucking difference!
[cheers and applause]
- Ah.
- Yeah.
[cheers and applause]